if i want to hire people in canada or
europe what do i need to know yep well
there's in
the
the idea is if you go into another
country
your u.s delaware c corp which is what
uh vcs like to invest in 99 of our
companies are that you either have to
create a subsidiary that can then run
you know have a bank account run payroll
or you do what's called an international
peo
and international peo just to help your
audience
is very similar to the peos the united
states professional employer
organizations and what they do
is they employ your company's employees
directly so so you are not actually the
employer of record the peo is and this
was this has been around for a long time
people did this since the 90s i i
started using a peo in new york in the
90s yeah exactly and it was a great
innovation but it wasn't until coveted
hit and and all of us went kind of
remote but the real major benefit you
got was that
by pooling all these employees across
many different companies you could they
could negotiate really good benefits
packages and and save you money on the
benefits packages of course it was a
little bit of like they created value
and then their fees were mysteriously
almost the exact number of the value go
figure funny how that works 150 bucks a
month 125 bucks a month
yeah
i basically and then you you could
literally do the calculation okay i've
hit
you know 50 employees it's costing me 70
000 an hr person
to come in and manage this would be x
amount okay that's exactly it but now
when and i don't know if you've seen
this across your portfolio days and i
assume you have
when covet hit people started moving
away from san francisco and new york and
austin and moving to all these other
states and so companies found themselves
having employees
in many different states overnight which
means you have state and local tax
requirements meaning
you have to register in that state to do
business and you have to register to pay
payroll taxes and what's cool about peos
is that was like kind of like a side
benefit that they've always done because
again the employers are working for the
peo and so no one really assigned a lot
of value to that but now we've actually
seen the peo market share in cruise
clients go from 15
to 30 percent
in one year so doubled it is it feels
like it's just picking up steam now the
alternative is your friendly cpa firm
like us will actually do your state and
local tax compliance but it's not
something we love
and it's kind of nice to simplify your
life and let the peo do it
and so that was like the major catalyst
for national peo uh adoption and then
a funny kind of little thing happened
with covid where founders historically
you may see this too they historically
had hired internationally
in a cluster or a center of excellence
so they might have in canada
or we have a toronto office in canada
you get five or six people
the costs of setting up there for us and
the bank accounts and managing it gets
spread across five people it suddenly
makes sense that's exactly it or in
india argentina ukraine all these places
and so in an international peo was the
same thing where you didn't have to set
up a subsidiary which costs a lot of
legal dollars and compliance dollars and
an entity in that country would employ
your international employees directly
the same thing we just covered now the
interesting thing that we're seeing
is that all of a sudden founders said to
themselves if i'm going to hire
internationally
why don't i just pick the best people
regardless of what country they're worse
so so no more centers of excellence as
or maybe not as much
and capitalism is amazing a whole host
of companies that are international pos
and i don't know if you want to get into
any names i can name the names if you
want i'll leave their names out i don't
when every time i mention a name then
the competitor or somebody else gets mad
at me so i always just totally extract
it yeah so so these companies have
filled the void and now
almost like a virtual layer can let you
hire in all not all but most countries
across the world it's kind of like you
know some of these payment processors
will allow you to accept payments from
190 countries overnight because you
dropped in some code that's what's
happening with these peos you drop in
this little bit of code you start a
relationship with them and you know
sometimes employees also have to figure
things out because they might have been
domiciled let's say uh in california and
then they decided they were going to go
to florida or austin but they kept their
place in california now where are they
paying taxes okay where did they spend
most of the month
what is your system saying where are
they withholding taxes from you might
get into a situation where you're worth
holding taxes in the wrong place and you
need somebody to help you with that too
that happens a lot
and
it's a hot button for a lot of employees
who moved either nationally
internationally because
california new york where a lot of
startup employees were are high tax
states yeah they they if they're gonna
move we see people moving all over but
the generally lower tax states
they want that change to happen
immediately it's more dollars in their
paycheck so yes but operating all this
stuff
actually takes a lot of work and on the
international side the cool thing about
these services is they there's an
emotion i feel like there's an emotional
benefit to being able to call yourself
an employee even if you're in another
country and oftentimes there's a
tangible benefit where you can get
benefits like you know the
like there's people need benefits
wherever they live and so having this
international po aspect actually solves
a couple of those problems and makes
recruiting these all-stars a heck of a
lot easier